[Musique]
et si les religions pouvait faire partie
de la solution
ça peut paraître absurde comme question
parce que quand on écoute l'actualité
quand on discute entre amis ou en
famille on a plutôt l'impression
qu'elles font clairement partie du
problème
c'est vrai que elles sont accusées a
toujours à tort de créer un mauvais choc
des rencontres de favoriser le sexisme
de maintenir une société patriarcale
elles sont parfois soupçonnée d'être
homophobe
on leur demande si elles sont pas trop
traditionalistes ou conservatrices
parfois elles servent de justification
pour de la violence elles ont été des
masques pour des croisades des guerres
des systèmes de domination ou
d'oppression l on était la justification
aussi du terrorisme récemment souvent
vous avez remarqué quand on est en
famille pour les fêtes ce sera bientôt
le cas pour dîner il ya une règle un peu
implicite comme ça cette année on parle
de tout mais pas politique et par
religion
et puis en général il ya toujours un
tonton cas une solution parfaite aux
problèmes du monde c'est moi je propose
qu'on supprime toutes les religions dans
le monde
bien sûr super facile en plus c'est vrai
je comprends parce que quand les
religions sont pas la cause d'un
problème
elles sont la cible du problème en ce
moment l'antisémitisme repointe le bout
de son nez sous un nouveau visage encore
plus vicieux qu'avant dans le monde
entier les juives sont victimes
d'attentats ou qu'ils aillent
l'islamophobie a atteint un niveau
jamais atteint auparavant dans notre
pays on enferme les musulmans dans des
camps en chine on est les exterminer en
birmanie au moyen-orient quand on est
chrétien il vaut mieux choisir entre
partir ou mourir
bref globalement quand on regarde de
loin on a plutôt l'impression que les
religions font clairement partie du
problème
j'ai grandi dans une école où il y avait
à peine deux cents élèves
la moitié des 200 enfants étaient
internes
parce que placé par la dass qui est
devenu la zone et on pouvait compter
dans ses 200 enfants 42 nationalités
chaque année on avait le même petit
rituel à la rentrée on venait accroché
un drapeau
sur notre pays d'origine pour montrer la
diversité de cette école tous les
mercredis matin il y avait sept
enseignants cette religion qui était
enseigné pardon est pratiqué dans
l'enceinte de l'école et nos enseignants
appelée cette école l'école arc-en-ciel
en référence à la philosophie et
pédagogie de nelson mandela en afrique
du sud
quand je suis rentrée au collège
c'était vraiment l'extrême inverse je
suis rentré dans un établissement qui
était dix fois plus grand donc de 1000
élèves si on sait compter
et dans cet établissement on avait une
très grande majorité voire ne peut pas
dire quasi totalité des élèves blancs
plutôt issus de milieux bourgeois très
favorisés de famille chrétienne parfois
devenu athée et dans cette période du
collège je vais subir comme beaucoup de
jeunes malheureusement une période de
harcèlement d'intimidation d'agressions
parfois d'attouchements et je me demande
au collège
pourquoi est-ce que je suis l'objet
comme ça de ce harcèlement scolaire
en réfléchissant je me disais dans
l'école arc en ciel où j'avais grandi
finalement on m'a appris à être moi-même
on m'a aidé à développer cette
singularité on m'a donné les outils pour
m'accomplir m'accepter tels que je suis
complètement grandir à ma façon
pas de bol au collège j'ai voulu être
comme tout le monde
alors tout ce qui dépasse on le coupe
quand je suis rentrée au lycée je
continue à interroger le harcèlement
était terminé mais je me disais pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai été victime de
harcèlement comme ça et j'apprends que
la directrice de mon école primaire
reçoit la légion d'honneur
alors je me rends à la cérémonie tout
content je lui dire je vais enfin lui
poser la question mais est ce qu'il y
avait un secret pour que dans sept
écoles primaires on puisse vivre
ensemble en harmonie comme ça avec
toutes les religions et nationalités
représentées et me dit oui bien sûr
samuel c'était grâce à votre diversité
jeudi grâce à notre diversité mais en
général la diversité c'est plutôt un
obstacle à surmonter qu'une solution
toute trouvée et me dit non non non non
parce que souvent on dit malgré la
diversité là moi je vous dis grâce à
votre diversité
alors je vais demander mais comment est
ce qu'on fait pour vivre ensemble grâce
à votre diversité et musique vous savez
samuel les religions elles existent les
différences existent elles vont pas
disparaître du jour au lendemain la
question n'est pas de savoir si on est
pour ou contre la question c'est de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et moi en
tant que directrice j'ai voulu garder le
meilleur et enlever le pire parce que
vous savez ce sont samuel la seule
alternative à la coexistence
c'est là qu'au destruction à vous de
choisir je suis resté un peu sur cette
phrase sur un tri chez moi et puis l'été
suivant je participe à un rassemblement
international du scoutisme avec des
scouts du monde entier de toutes les
religions de toutes les cultures de tous
les pays
et un matin nous distribuent cette
petite phrase sur un papier que j'ai
glissé dans ma poche et que j'ai vu plus
tard il y avait écrit vivons ensemble
comme des frères ou nous périrons
ensemble comme des imbéciles
martin luther king est donc là j'ai
repensé à ma directrice et je me suis
dit en fait finalement quand on a
différentes origines différentes
convictions religion vivre ensemble
c'est pas tellement une option c'est
plutôt une obligation
aujourd'hui dans le monde 84% des êtres
humains se reconnaissent dans une
conviction religieuse en france à peu
près deux tiers qui se considèrent
proche ou lointain d'une communauté avec
un bon tiers qui s'affirme vraiment
croyants et cette diversité cette
réalité de pluralisme de religion c'est
un fait social pour la plupart des
croyants dans le monde
avoir une fois avoir une conviction ça
donne une raison de se lever le matin
ça peut être un moteur à l'engagement ça
peut donner du sens à une espérance et
ses convictions intimes sont parfois
utiles justement à l'intérêt général
et là en fait je voudrais poser ma
question de départ
et si en fait ce n'était pas les
convictions qui pouvait faire partie de
la solution
cette substance qui se transmet
notamment grâce aux religions mais du
coup et si ce n'était pas les
convictions religieuses droite et quelle
qu'elle soit qui pouvait faire partie de
la solution pour la plupart des
musulmans pour des milliards de
musulmans dans le monde le vrai jihad ça
veut dire le dépassement de soi même
pour être mis au service des autres pour
des millions de juifs dans le monde
obéir à la torah ça veut dire c'est
écrit dans le pentateuque aime ton
prochain comme toi même pour des
millions de chrétiens lire l'évangile ça
veut dire aimer ses ennemis et tendre
l'autre joue pour les deux tiers
d'actifs d'agnostiques dans notre pays
peut être que la démocratie où les
valeurs humanistes et humanitaires sont
bien plus que des valeurs superficielles
alors pourquoi est ce que quand ses
convictions intimes sont mises au
service du bien commun elles sont si peu
connues et elles font beaucoup plus de
bruit quand elles sont mis au service du
mal peut-être parce qu'un arbre qui
s'abat ça fait toujours beaucoup plus de
bruit qu'une forêt qui germe mais en
même temps cette forêt qui gère mais
elle a déjà de nombreux héros derrière
elle
c'est à cause de sa conviction que lech
walesa s'est engagée contre la dictature
du soviétisme c'est grâce à sa
conviction que desmond tootoo a lancé le
tribunal d' amnistie de réconciliation
en afrique du sud
c'est toujours grâce à leur conviction
que jean vanier s'est engagé toute sa
vie pour les personnes handicapées que
l'abbé pierre à fond d emmaüs et que
martin luther king s'est interrogé en
lisant l'évangile sur comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui je peux répondre à la
ségrégation raciale
jusqu'à cette action non violente et son
fameux discours i have a dream appelant
à faire sonner toutes les cloches de la
liberté
lorsque j'ai eu 21 ans je suis parti
faire le tour du monde avec quatre amis
un juif un chrétien musulman un athée ce
pas une blague
et on est partis repérer toutes les
initiatives inter convictionnels au
service de la paix pour voir si en fait
ses convictions religieuses spirituelles
ou athées dans le monde parfois été
utilisés comme des capitaux à investir
au service du bien commun
alors on a cherché des initiatives on a
rencontré beaucoup 435 précisément et
plusieurs initiatives ont beaucoup
marqué je pense à hull en particulier la
maintenant dans un bidonville à côté de
nairobi au kenya le bidonville s'appelle
kibera et on ya rencontré des femmes
musulmanes et chrétiennes qui ont décidé
de mettre en commun ce que le contenu de
leurs textes leur disais pour faire face
à leur solitude dans leur combat
respectif
le point commun de ces femmes c'est
qu'elles étaient toutes mères
célibataires et qu' elle était
confrontée à l'éducation d'un enfant
dans une famille monoparentale est elle
partagée ce que l'islam et le
christianisme avait à dire comme
ressources pour faire face ensemble à
cette situation
plus tard dans le tour du monde c'est
pas le choc des rencontres il rend
compte de choc
j'ai rencontré hassan hassani les
musulmans bosniaques d'un peuple qui a
été victime d'un génocide en 1995 le
dernier génocide en europe et sur le
lieu du massacre de srebrenica où il a
perdu son père et son frère il nous
raconte comment est-ce qu'il s'est caché
sous des corps lorsque les serbes ont
commencé à éliminer toutes les personnes
qu'ils avaient rassemblé et après
plusieurs heures d'attenté
comment est-ce qu'il est sorti et
comment est-ce qu'il a repris sa vie
comment est-ce qu'il a plus contribué à
près à identifier les 8192 corps des
victimes du massacre de srebrenica un
massacre qui a aussi été commis en août
une religion par les bourreaux un de mes
camarades jocelyn le regarde et lui dit
mais hassan aujourd'hui tous les jours
tu vis avec les serbes qui sont
coupables du génocide dans lequel sont
morts ton père est ton frère comment est
ce que tu fais pour vivre avec eux tu as
pas de haine envers eux hélas ça ne
s'arrête de parler ils nous regardent et
puis y prend un grand sourire
il nous dit vous savez moi je suis
musulman j'ai pas assez de place dans
mon coeur pour aimer dieu et haïr les
autres c'est une question que je me suis
posée par rapport à ses initiatives
interprofessionnelles rencontrer partout
dans le monde
est ce que finalement on parle pas trop
de liberté de conviction et pas assez de
responsabilités de conviction bien sûr
il ya les droits de l'homme qui proclame
que la liberté de conviction et absolue
article 18 chacun est libre d'avoir une
religion de ne pas en avoir dans changés
de la pratiquer seul ou en commun en
public ou en privé toujours article 18
mais peut-être que à cette liberté on
ajouterait une deuxième brique celle de
la responsabilité si j'ai une conviction
qu'est-ce que j'en fais au service des
autres et de la société et comment est
ce qu'elle peut être d'intérêt général
une conviction d'intérêt général il ya
dix ans j'ai fondé un mouvement
d'éducation populaire qui s'appelle
coexister qui rassemble des jeunes juifs
chrétiens musulmans athées agnostiques
dans toute la france qui essaye de vivre
ensemble toujours grâce à leur
différence et pas malgré elle et je me
suis interrogé pourquoi est ce que tous
ces jeunes finalement font preuve de
responsabilité de conviction est ce que
il ya quelque chose et règles des
principes un secret qui fait que eux
sont engagés dans cette démarche alors
que d'autres font exactement inverse
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont choisie dans
cet énorme panel qui va du bataclan à
martin luther king et je crois que j'ai
trouvé je crois que j'ai trouvé cinq
petites règles qui sont le point commun
de tous ces jeunes qui sont là et qui
persévèrent à créer du lien dans une
situation vous le savez comme moi qui ai
pas toujours facile en ce moment règle
numéro 1 connaître connaître c'est à
dire parler aux autres parler avec les
autres plutôt que parler des autres en
leur absence connaître c'est aussi
respecter plutôt que tolérée toléré en
français ça veut dire accepter l'autre
par défaut pour comprendre le poids de
ce mot insuffisant imaginez que vous
disiez à quelqu'un que vous aimez je
tolère
respectez ça témoigne d'une estime un
choix personnel connaître c'est aussi
cherché à centre connaître comme dit le
coran sourate 49 verser 12
je vous ai fait en plusieurs nations et
plusieurs tribus pour que vous vous en
connaissiez est toujours le coran
sourate 5 verser 48
si j'avais voulu faire de vous une seule
communauté je leur ai fait mais je vous
ai fait différent pour que vous vous
surpassez dans les bonnes oeuvres
règle numéro 2 douter doutez pas douter
de soi ni de son engagement mais douter
à la manière de descartes des cartes qui
remettait en cause en permanence ses
certitudes quand une conviction devient
une certitude elle ouvre la porte à
devenir un dogmatisme c'est à dire une
prison mentale qui peut tout justifier
et qui peut tous légitimement douter
c'est accepter aussi que l'autre n'est
pas enfermé dans une case il ya mille et
une façons d'être croyant ou athée et
chaque conviction et singulière à celui
qui la porte
règle numéro 3 être juste être juste
c'est promouvoir et défendre l'égalité
de traitement entre toutes ses
convictions qui s'exprime et surtout
entre celles et ceux qui portent ses
convictions comment est ce que vous
croyez que l'équipe de france a gagné la
coupe du monde alors qu'ils arrivent de
milieux sociaux territoriaux extrêmement
variés on voyait leur nom sur l'arc de
triomphe avec leur ville de naissance le
jour de la victoire
ils ont peut-être gagné la coupe du
monde pour plein de raisons notamment
parce qu'il ya une seule règle qui
s'applique dans cette équipe diversifiée
une seule le football si la même règle a
été respectée pour toutes et tous
peut-être que déjà on a plus de chances
d'avoir une responsabilité de conviction
promouvoir aussi l'égalité c'est
comprendre qu a pas de justice sans paix
et pas de paix sans justice
et comme le dit le talmud qui tue un
homme tue toute l'humanité et qui sauve
un homme sauve toute l'humanité est
aujourd'hui moi je fais un rêve avec
vous très concrètement que ce soit les
juifs qui sont en première ligne contre
l'islamophobie comme les musulmans qui
sont en première ligne contre
l'antisémitisme parce que le sort des
opprimés c'est le sort de toute la
société
règle numéro 4 agir ensemble
quand on a fait ce tour du monde on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément de diversité théologique et
que en fait c'est plus que de la
diversité il ya beaucoup de divergences
et de désaccord et de points de vue
contradictoires entre croyants et
non-croyants déjà mais aussi entre
croyants et même dans cet immense
contradiction que sont toutes les
théologies du monde ya des chercheurs
américains et une étude américaine a
prouvé que
qui sont venus voir si il avait ne
serait-ce qu'une seule phrase commune à
toutes les sagesses de l'humanité est ce
que les confucianiste taoïste into his
bouddhistes hindous musulmans juifs
chrétiens athées avait une seule phrase
en commun ils en ont trouvé une venant
trouver une ils ont fait une thèse là
dessus elle s'appelle la règle d'or la
golden drum et cette règle d'or elle dit
tout simplement elle est présente dans
tous les textes et sagesse fait aux
autres ce que tu veux qu'on te fasse et
ne fais pas aux autres ce que tu ne veux
pas qu'on te fasse
la règle numéro 4 toujours agir ensemble
c'est comprendre diversité de conviction
unité dans l'action diversité de
conviction unité dans l'action
l'unité c'est pas l'uniformité être unis
ça veut pas dire être semblables ce qui
nous ressemble n'est pas ce qui nous
rassemble est d'ailleurs pour rester sur
l'équipe de france sur son maillot il
est écrit de nos différences nous
rassemble et al'inverse la diversité
c'est pas la division
ce qui nous distingue ce n'était pas
forcément quelque chose qui nous sépare
donc comprendre tout le poids de cet
adage tout simple diversité de
conviction unité dans l'action c'est
rendre possible que dans des théologies
qui se contredisent entre elles elles
puissent converger parfois sur la santé
l'environnement le climat le sans
abrisme écologie l'agriculture et tant
d'autres causes
règle numéro 5 persévérer il ya
tellement de bonnes raisons de
désespérer les uns sont trop victimaire
chacun se plaint ma communauté n'est pas
assez compris mon identité n'est pas
respectée je suis discriminer je suis
exclu la n est plus forte
ceux qui veulent détruire le monde sont
plus puissants que ceux qui veulent le
construire tellement de raison de
désespérer un jour j'étais dans un
monastère en israël avec un moine qui
accueille pour se reposer sur une
journée des familles qui ont perdu des
proches dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien des deux côtés pour
passer un temps ensemble et partager
leur deuil et un jour il ya une femme
qui arrive dans un groupe mélangeant des
mers israélienne et des mères
palestiniennes
et puis elle se met à pleurer dans le
monastère en disant on n'y arrivera pas
on n'y arrivera pas le terrain de la
paix n'est pas possible on pourra jamais
y arriver là le moine qui se reprend et
qui commence à l'engueuler et qui lui
dit on n'a pas le droit on n'a pas le
droit de désespérer du coeur de l'homme
jamais jamais alors voilà cinq petites
règles qui peuvent aider à ajouter à la
liberté de conviction la responsabilité
de conviction imaginez si demain tous
les penseurs auteurs athées et croyants
converger pour dire que dans la
divergence de leurs convictions ils sont
d'accord pour dire qu'il ya une
injonction climatique aujourd'hui les
conséquences
alors est-ce que les convictions peuvent
faire partie de la solution
oui à condition de se connaître de
douter être juste d'agir ensemble et de
persévérer toujours toujours et encore
toujours merci
[Applaudissements]